nobody's gonna know nobody's gonna know
they're gonna know
how would they know how would they know
that's cardi b revealing to fans how she
managed to hide her baby bump
before announcing her pregnancy in the
tick tock video the rapper wore
a skin-tight blue ensemble oh yes honey
posing against a white wall the star
didn't look a day pregnant as she
flaunted her curves
and pulled a few poses nobody's going to
know
but then in another clip cardi is seen
filming herself
as she stands in front of a mirror in
the same exact outfit
now this is where it gets wild oh
snappity snap snap
cardi turns to the side to reveal she
was indeed pregnant at the time
let's play that again nobody's gonna
know
nobody's gonna know they're gonna know
how would they know how would they know
and we did a little digging back in june
cardi b
posted pics wearing the same outfit
weeks before she revealed her pregnancy
now that the big news is out cardi has
been showing off her growing bump
on 4th of july the proud mom took a
casual walk wearing a sheer
body hugging leopard dress while
playfully talking smack about california
barbecues
california i'm going to one of your
barbecues today i ain't staying home
today
i'm not with them vegan burgers because
your [ __ ] californians y'all be
doing too much
i probably made a [ __ ] cauliflower
hot dog
i'm not with that shy eye the rapper
also gave a glimpse of her baby kicking
in her belly
oh my god but the cutest posts
are definitely her beautiful maternity
photos with hubby offset
and their two-year-old daughter culture
i love everything about motherhood
and can we just take a moment to gush
over how adorable culture will be as a
big sister
i don't know i just get too emotional
and come to my kid
in this photo the proud mom predicted
how her two-year-old will handle being
the big sister
pointing out that they will have the
same age difference as cardi
and her younger sister hennessy she
wrote i just
know these two will love each other so
much and argue
so much since they're three years apart
just like me and honey
but one thing for sure is they'll have
each other's back like no one else ever
will
it's gonna mean everything next to this
pic of offset cradling her baby bump
cardi wrote we listened to each other
communicated
prayed and then god blessed us and our
family with another little blessing
our home feels so blissful and very busy
but we are ready
and so happy thank you so much everyone
for the congrats and well wishes
in 2019 cardi told et she was already
looking to give culture some siblings
what does it mean to be a mother it
means everything it's
it's like a feeling that it's
indescribable
it's like love joy it's a
switch you know what i'm saying it's
like
an automatic smile so it's everything
everything so if one brings you this
much joy
would you double the joy i want to have
more kids
you do yeah more kids that sounds like
many
i mean you know
how whatever my body could take i feel
like
the more my baby grows i see like the
different
levels and there's just gonna be
different levels all the time from one
year old
to going around chasing them making sure
they don't put things in their mouth
to you know five-year-old when they
start going to school learning things
interacting with other kids there's
always going to be different levels
yeah yeah yeah of course all right we're
waiting on the next few